[Music]
curry lobs it in reeves breaks it up
nicely that's outstanding defense
polishing reeves
monk back to james
shoulder feet lakers led early by 14
warriors came back beat careless with
the basketball turnovers gives them open
threes in transition
nice feet inside james to westbrook
those two have connected a number of
times already that's an outstanding pass
but this is just a good screen by monk
and that's just an outstanding pass from
james when they put james at the elbow
he's such a good initiator of offense
when did you change
[Music]
james down low double team through some
contact count it and won
and i like that move
they switch
and he seals
with physicality and he goes to the rim
and they're gonna
[Music]
james looking
puts up a three puts it in lebron james
with four tenths of a second remaining
idol porter throws it up that will not
count coaster ride for both teams in
this game
the long three-point
lakers wanted to travel on curry james
gets into the lane layup it's good and
the foul
and lakers back within six
to consistently score so the things that
they can get done in transition
are absolutely critical that was an
impressive defensive play he's had a
couple like good blocks today
james season opening drives inside and
the flood
38 for james
as the five for point guard
on offense you put him in pick-a-roll
action
small guy is now in rotation having to
defend it his ability to turn the corner
use that upper body strength and finish
witnessing greatness
from anthony misses the three toscano
anderson couldn't control it a new 14.
james three-pointer ties the game
makes it
97-94
is up three and it's lebron james
putting his stamp on this ball game
[Music]
james long three-pointer now he ties the
game
46 for lebron james a season high it's
down to long ball next trip
little he wants to shoot another three
here
heat checks rarely work
[Applause]
james puts up a three
lebron james gives the lakers their
first lead of the second half that's a
heat check good defense doesn't matter
hand up so what mama
there goes that man you gotta look at
the great play and say no you need to
bring it across half court that's on you
[Applause]
this is stella defense active hands
defending the guy taking it out of
bounds creates the turnover